es el rodeo del ganado bravo un evento
que se produce una vez al año pero que
había sido suspendido a causa de la
pandemia
buscar hace parte de los vaqueros
andinos o chacras dedicados a la
ganadería desde la época de la colonia
que no están dispuestos a perder su
cultura
aquí aquí son un año que no mostraba
pero sí es un poquito triste que se haya
perdido estos eventos gracias a dios ya
por las vacunas todo eso ya empezamos a
otra vez reactivar poco a poco yo sé que
todavía toca seguimos cuidando pero creo
que aquí en el páramo el aire es limpio
todo estos eventos creo que no corremos
ningún peligro en mi pensar
entre los todos las barreras otra forma
de rodean y canadá de vuelta al rodeo
oscar defiende la tradición un legado
que aprende nuevas generaciones juntos
sus mayores ya empiezan desde pequeño a
cielo de los corrales así empiezan a
estar claro que a veces nos explicamos
pero allá en los páramos de alguna cosa
de esas ya más de tres mil metros de
altura donde familia entrega experiencia
cultural a su nieto uno de los nuevos
rostros que asumirán las lindas y la
complicada tradición de nosotros jamás
podemos olvidar por el frío por la
lluvia el sombrero y el poncho es la
vestimenta que cubre el frente mente que
en los puestos
un nuevo llamado al ruedo que hace soñar
a este joven que ya busca dejar su
huella al pie de la montaña
concluye el rodeo y disfrutan de los
frutos de la tierra una forma de
mantener contacto con una serranía
indomable